let's go ahead and open things up today
with a question that might seem like
it's incredibly unrelated to the title
of the video so if you guys go to three
b-1b coast live link is in the
description you've all been there for
some of the warm-up animations I want
you to just make an an estimate for the
following question it looks like a
couple of you have already started
coming in with answers here consider the
numbers between one trillion and a
trillion plus a thousand K so this range
of a thousand integers that's pretty
high which of the following would you
guessed is closest to the proportion of
these numbers that are prime so if you
were to go through the painstaking
process of you know looking at all of
those numbers between a trillion and a
trillion plus a thousand considering
which of them are prime what do you
guess is the relevant proportion there
so don't worry about getting it right or
wrong I'm mostly curious where people's
intuitions are on this one so while we
don't necessarily have to do those
painstaking calculations I have gone
ahead and written up a simple program
that can do that for us so if we hop on
over to Python it's not exactly the most
sophisticated program for getting
Prime's in the world but it'll get the
job done for us so if I type something
like get Prime's between 0 and 50 you
know we take a look ok it's got 2 3 5 7
Oh your favorite prime numbers between 0
and 50 you're gonna find in there but
maybe you don't like that range maybe
you want to look between a thousand and
a thousand 50 and there you go there's
the primes between a thousand and 1,050
and there's fewer of them in general as
you get bigger and bigger the primes get
sparser and sparser essentially because
each one has more options for what it
could factor into you know if you're
just doing the guess and check on
something like 143 you just have to
check all the numbers up to around its
square root whereas if you're checking
around a trillion you have to check on
the order of you know something like a
million numbers all the primes up to a
million whether or not they go into it
so you might think that when we let's
say we define the list where we're going
to get all of the Prime's
you know get the primes between a
trillion which is 10 to the 12th and a
trillion plus a thousand this this
involves a lot of number crunching to
actually find those Prime's and you can
see by the fact that you know the
program I wrote isn't going to be the
most efficient thing in the world it
takes
a little bit of time before it gets
there so we can we can look at that list
in just a moment but before I want to
properly take a look at what what
everybody thinks and we have a great
split oh I love questions that split up
the audience like this that's always fun
so what do you think what do you think
is the actual density of crimes up there
oh the correct answer is only third
place usually in lockdown math the
correct answer is always at top so this
is exciting for me it seems like most or
the the largest number of people thought
that D one out of 250 that there would
only be four Prime's
in that range after that it was people
who thought only one in a thousand that
up there you know Prime's are so rare
they only come one in every thousand the
correct answer
the closest proportion here would have
been one in 25 so a lot more frequent
than people might have thought and
what's interesting is actually if you
ask this question to a mathematician
they would be able to pretty quickly
tell you what the correct answer is not
because they're doing all that number
crunching and in fact if you were to
talk to a mathematician they would look
at this problem they would do a small
little calculation in there's a head and
they'd say the closest is one in 25 but
really it's going to be closer to you
know one in every 27 or 28 that would be
a bit more accurate and you might wonder
how they do that because if we look at
the number crunching that our computer
had to do it had to check all of the
potential factors for all of the numbers
we were looking at and it does give us
all of the primes between a trillion and
a trillion plus a thousand so as you can
see there there sparser than they are
for just the numbers between zero and a
thousand but there's a meaningful number
of them you know we've got one trillion
751 one trillion 787 the Boeing
engineers are probably pleased that
that's in there and the actual length of
that list is 37 so there's 37 Prime's in
there so the proportion out of the
thousand is 0.37 or the way we were
phrasing it was 1 out of something so we
might take the reciprocal of that and do
a thousand divided by the number in
there and it's about 1 in every 27 but
what the mathematician would do is they
would say I know this very cute fact
about prime numbers which is the density
of prime numbers near a given value like
a trillion is around the natural log so
I'm going to type math dot log here
which takes a natural logarithm of that
number and we can you know check if you
want what does the documentation tell us
it says this returns the logarithm of X
to a given base if the base is not
specified it returns the natural
logarithm which is log base e of X and
just as a reminder if anyone needs a
little reminding on what logarithms mean
we talked about this all in the last
lecture so feel free to pop over but
when you have an expression like Ln X
which is telling us the log with base e
of x equals y that is saying the same
thing as e to the power y equals x it's
asking the question e to the what equals
x so for example the natural log of 10
it's it's around 2.3 and that's a kind
of useful value to know if you want to
make conversions between Exponential's
written with E versus Exponential's
written with 10 that the natural log of
10 is around 2.3 so that's saying the
same thing is e to the 2.3 equals 10 now
the cutesy fact here is that prime
numbers their density is actually kind
of related to this natural logarithm if
we went over and we took the natural log
of a trillion which was the number
defining our range at the lower end of
that range you'd see that it's 27 and
that was about the ratio we were looking
at before right a thousand divided by
the length of our list of primes I mean
that's that's quite close and the fact
that that happens at all is I don't I
might not call that my favorite piece of
math because I use that term a lot but
it's definitely going to make the list
of top 5 favorite pieces of math that
the log with base e has anything to do
with prime numbers so I want to show you
another kind of cute fact associated
with the relationship between natural
logs and primes because you might wonder
why is it that we call this thing the
natural logarithm there's lots of
logarithms lots of different bases what
makes this one more natural and I think
the more often you see it show up in
nature the more that name starts to kind
of make sense so I'm going to play a
game that will seem truly strange for a
moment I'm going to take an infinite
series for example one that's you know a
favorite among a lot of people if you
take 1 over 1 plus 1 over 4 plus 1 over
9
plus one over sixteen and in general
you're always taking one over N squared
and you add up all of those numbers if
you keep adding and adding them they'll
stay below a certain bound and they'll
actually approach a certain number and
it was this open question in Europe it
was posed in Bazzle by I think one of
the Bernoulli's for a while like what is
the number that this equals and
eventually euler genius of the day was
able to prove that it equals pi squared
divided by six which is very beautiful
the idea that pi is it all related to
just adding up the reciprocals of
squares but it gets crazier than that
I'm gonna play this weird game that's
going to kick out terms that don't look
like prime numbers keep the prime
numbers and then also scale down ones
that are sufficiently prime similar for
us I'll show you what I mean so one is
not at all a prime we're not even going
to include it two is a prime so I'm
going to keep that one over two squared
term three is a prime so I'm going to
keep the one over three squared term
four it's not a prime but I'm not going
to kick it out because it is the power
of a prime so I'm going to say that one
over four squared term can stay but
because you're only the square of a
prime I'm gonna scale you down by a half
yeah it's kind of a way of saying you
look sort of like a prime but because
you're only a power of it I'm scaling
you down by that power 5 is a prime so
we keep the fifth term six not a prime
not a power of a prime we don't like it
at all it gets kicked out seven we keep
it and you can sort of see where I'm
going here but all right a couple more
examples because it's such a bizarre way
to manipulate a series you would think
that this isn't going to get us anything
nice at all eight it's a power of a
prime but because it's a cube I'm going
to scale it down by a factor of three so
I'm going to take one-third of the
eighth term nine it's the square of a
prime so we'll take one half of the
ninth term ten gets kicked out we
ignored entirely eleven stays as is and
on and on so each one of your terms
looks like the power of a prime 1 over P
K and because this series for squaring
them all it's 1 over the power of that
prime squared but we scale it down by
whatever that power is
right now because we've manipulated this
in a pretty chaotic way I mean the
primes are distributed in a pretty
random fashion you might think that this
is completely uncomputable it's just a
crazy situation and it's going to be
smaller you know for sure it's going to
be smaller than the PI squared over 6
because we left out the one we left out
a lot of composite numbers and prime
powers bigger than with the power bigger
than one we scaled down so it's
definitely a smaller number you might be
able to guess where this is going based
on the title of the video what it ends
up equaling is the natural log of what
it was before of PI squared over 6 and
that's not just true for this particular
sequence of sums of squares there's a
number of other formulas that get us
something related to prime where we
could say something related to PI which
is evidently related to primes in a way
that's um I mean you play the same game
and you you have this weird fashion of
taking logarithms and not just any
logarithm the log base e so just to talk
through what I mean in this other
context if you take 1 minus 1/3 plus 1/5
minus 1/7 plus 1/9 and kind of alternate
back and forth between the odd numbers
you get pi divided by 4 I have a video
all about this mythology also has a
video about it if you're curious very
beautiful why it's true but even
stranger is when we play this game of
keeping the primes and kicking out
others so one we're going to kick out if
we keep the third term that's negative 3
then the 5 we keep that the 7 I guess
it's a minus 1/7 the 9 we keep it but we
scale it down because it's the square of
a prime and in this case because we're
only looking at odd numbers it looks
like we're keeping quite a few of them
we have to get bigger before we kick
them out so like 15 that gets kicked out
17 is positive it gets to stay as is 19
gets to stay as is 21 gets kicked out 23
gets to stay so a very bizarre thing I
mean now the pluses and minuses they
don't alternating nicely it's like minus
plus minus plus minus plus plus minus
minus it's a it almost seems like a
random sequence 25 we can scale that
down because it's 5 squared 1 over 25
and this doesn't equal PI fourths
anymore but it does equal the natural
logarithm of PI fourths so evidently
there's this relationship between taking
logarithms with base E which is to say
answering the question e to the what
equals a value and these sort of prime
patterns and it's quite beautiful when
you think about it because if you look
at like this entire sequence up here
it's going to equal some number such
that e to that number is related to pi
so you have this formula that's
interrelating all of the prime numbers
and their powers for that matter
excluding the composite so it's still a
cool sequence it's not just like all the
integers we're taking e raising e to the
power of that sum and you get something
related to pi I mean clearly better than
Euler's formula I think you'd have to
agree so we might at the end of the
lesson get to why that's true it'll
depend on how much time there is but the
next two facts I'll show you we will
definitely explain why they're true so
we're gonna play a couple more games
with series here these ones are gonna be
a little bit simpler faxed to think
about than the first two that I showed
but the relation with primes is just oh
man if that doesn't make you love math I
don't know it would but if we play it an
alternating game that doesn't go through
all the odd numbers but it goes through
every number so I'm gonna take 1 minus
1/2 plus 1/3 minus 1/4 on and on and you
might visualize this with a number line
where I'm going between 0 & 1 here when
we take 1 minus 1/2 you're hopping
backwards by 1/2 and then plus 1/3
you're hopping forward by a smaller
amount minus 1/4 you'd hop backwards by
a still smaller amount then plus 1/5 and
then backwards might get you here and
then forward might get you something
like that and you're alternating back
and forth and because each one is
smaller than the last you can probably
see that it has to zero in on some kind
of value and as a matter of fact it does
it's zeroes in on a value that's around
zero point six nine or so and more
precisely it comes in on the natural log
of two the answer to the question e
to what is equal to two kind of strange
don't you think that something like e
would show up with relation to just on
numbers oscillating back and forth like
this
and there's another relation that
natural logarithms have to a sequence
that looks like this you might ask what
happens if we don't alternate back and
forth but we add them all together and
what does that approach because in the
same way that you know when we added all
the squares the sum the sum of the
reciprocals of the squares that
approached a beautiful thing it was PI
squared over 6 you might think an even
more natural question to ask is don't
square them at all take 1 plus 1/2 plus
1/3 plus 1/4 on and on
what is this approach now as it happens
it actually it doesn't approach anything
no matter how small a number you choose
this sequence is eventually going to get
bigger than it so I could say keep
adding terms and eventually you'll get
bigger than 100 if you have some
patients keep adding terms and
eventually you'll get bigger than a
million and what kind of surprising
because each one of these numbers is
getting smaller and smaller so as you're
making your additions you would think
it's gonna slow down it won't get you
past something like a hundred but I can
explain to you why this is going to
happen that's actually a very pretty
proof if I group my terms
appropriately so I'm going to group a
third and a fourth together I'm going to
group all the numbers between a fifth
and an eighth all of the numbers between
a 9th and a 16th all of the numbers
between 1 over 17 and 1 over 32 so into
these groups that grow in size by powers
of two what I can say is that 1/3 plus
1/4 well both of those numbers are
bigger than 1/4 1/3 is bigger than 1/4
and well 1/4 isn't bigger but it's
exactly equal to but that does mean that
there's some yeah there some is
definitely going to be bigger than 1/4
times 1/4 which is the same as taking 2
times 1/4
similarly this sum here 1/5 plus 1/6
plus 1/7 plus 1/8 each one of those
terms is bigger than 1/8 all 4 of those
terms are bigger than 1/8 so the group
of them together is bigger than 4
eighths similarly over here all of the
numbers between a 9th and a 16th all
eight of those numbers are bigger than 1
in 16 so the sum altogether is bigger
than 8 times 1 over 16
and you might see where I'm going with
this you know here I have 16 members
that are all bigger than one in 30
excuse me
bigger than 1 in 32 talking while
writing and of course all of these are
just equal to 1/2 so this 2/4 is the
same as 1/2 4 eighths is the same as 1/2
8/16 that's 1/2 so in other words what I
can do is group all of my terms so that
the sum instead looks like taking 1 plus
1/2 plus 1/2 plus 1/2 on and on forever
and that you can see okay if I keep
going sufficiently long it is going to
get bigger and it also gives you a
little instinct that this might actually
be related to logarithms because the
size of our groupings grow according to
powers of 2 so if you were wondering how
long do I have to go before this Sun
gets bigger than 10 you might have the
instinct that hmm I'm gonna have to add
together let's see I have 1 and then the
rest of them are halves so I'm gonna
have to add together 18 different groups
that each look like 1/2 so I might have
to get up to the point where the size of
my group is like 2 to the 17th or 2 to
the 18th something like that and you
would be spot on that it grows well it
doesn't grow exponentially
it grows logarithmically because if
you're asking how far do you need to go
in order to get to that point there'll
be a logarithmic and as you might guess
it's actually the natural logarithm so
if I add up all of the terms to about 1
over N it ends up being approximately
the natural log of N and if you want to
get even more accurate it's the natural
log of n plus a certain constant this is
a constant we'll talk about later on in
the lesson but just for an order of
approximation this gives you the idea
that you need to get up to around the
natural log of n so I'm going to go
ahead and pull up the quiz and ask you
another question just to see if you've
been paying attention so far so our
question asks which of the following is
closest to the smallest value of n for
which the sum 1 plus 1/2 plus 1/3 plus
1/4 on and on you keep adding until you
get 1 over n how long do you have to go
until
some is bigger than a million okay so
remember your first instinct here might
have been that this entire sum converges
to something in the same way that when
you add the reciprocals of squares it
converges to pi squared divided by 6
very beautiful you might have thought
that you keep going to this and it
converges in fact what happens is it'll
always get larger but you can be more
quantitative than that and you can ask
how long does it take before this gets
larger than a million so I'll give you a
give you a little bit of time to think
through what the answer to that will be
and I will say because we're kind of
converting between e related things and
base-10 related things if you wanted a
little reminder I can pull up the fact
that the natural log of 10 is around 2.3
if you wanted to use that for estimation
purposes so just to see if you were
paying attention to the result that I've
just described of this thing growing
like a natural logarithm let's see how
you answer I don't give I'll give
another 20 seconds or so here
you
all right even if you're not necessarily
finished I'll go ahead and see where
people are on this one lock in the
answers and then explain where it comes
from so the correct answer is that it's
around ten to the four hundred thousand
or so which is a huge huge number the
estimated number of atoms in the
universe is around 10 to the 80th so it
would be as if each atom of the universe
had a universe inside of it that would
get us to ten to the hundred sixty then
each one of those had a universe inside
it that only gets us to ten to the 240
you'd have to keep iterating like that
over and over and it would even even
that crazy idea like mental thought for
how you can get up to a big number would
take forever to get you to something of
the size ten to the 400,000 all right
now the way that you would think about
something like this is to take a look at
what I just said when we add up all
these numbers up to the point 1 over N
it's about the natural log of n so what
you're looking for is the value when the
natural log of n is approximately a
million that's how long you have to go
before the sum gets bigger than a
million this is the same statement as
saying that n is about e to the power of
a million okay but of all of our answers
were expressed in terms of powers of ten
so in order to make the conversion I
would think to myself 10 to the what is
equal to e that way I'm going to be able
to make a little substitution here with
the power of 10 well this is asking me
what is the log base 10 of E and from
properties of logarithms like what we
learned last time this is the same as
asking log base E of 10 but we're taking
the reciprocal of that okay and another
way you could think about that is that e
to the 1 over x equals 10 that these two
expressions are the same so we're
looking for the natural log of 10 but we
take 1 over it now our estimation for
the natural log of 10 if you happen to
know it's around 2.3 all you would
really know for you need to know for
this one is like that it's a
roughly two or even that it's on the
order of one because all the exponents
and our options we're looking very
different so if you're asking what's 1/2
point 3 I mean very roughly it's like
like 1/2 so we could think of n as being
very very roughly something that's like
10 to the 1/2 to the 1 million just to
get us something kind of close so that
looks like it's 10 to the 500,000 and we
know that that 1/2 really should be a
little bit smaller because we're taking
1/2 point 3 not 1/2 so the number should
be something a little smaller than
500,000 and indeed of all the options
here there's there's one that's much
closer to 10 to the 500,000 than
anything else or like very rough
approximation were to get us there all
right so that's pretty fun now to start
explaining where on earth some of these
things are coming from like why is the
natural log present in these
circumstances I want to take a moment to
start talking about E and the role that
he plays in math and a way that I think
sometimes it can be a little bit
misunderstood so just to start off I'm
going to pick a number from the audience
so in your own time feel free to go to 3
B 1 B CO and enter whatever your
favorite number is but the thing I want
to talk about to begin here is how lots
of answer is coming in that's always fun
when you see a family of functions ok so
let's say we see something that looks
like pop on over here something that
looks like e to the R times X for
various different values of R this is
something you see all the time in
engineering in math and physics we
describe a bunch of different
Exponential's with some kind of
parameter like are sitting there and we
say depending on what R is this can give
us a shallower exponential growth
something that grows exponentially but a
little bit more slowly versus a steep
exponential growth ok once you're
writing things in terms of a family I
think a lot of people have this instinct
that like these are all of the functions
that e produces like D the number is
producing this beautiful family of
functions but it's important to realize
this is the same statement as creating a
family of functions that just like look
like a to the X with various different
bases where I could tweak what that
value of a is and so you know sometimes
it looks like
- to the power X sometimes it looks like
three to the power X yeah or four to the
power X tweaking that base gets us
various different Exponential's that's
actually playing the same game for
anyone that you have here like you know
the function 3 to the X taking powers of
three I can choose an R such that e to
the rx equals that and in fact there's
nothing special about e I could have
chosen as the base here something like
pi I could say look at the family of
Exponential's that look like pi to the R
times X it's not that pi is producing
these numbers or pi is related to this
family in a particular way it's a choice
that we're making to write it that way
and almost always the choice that we
make in physics and engineering and math
all over the place to write families of
Exponential's is with e so the right
question to ask isn't what does he have
to do with such a family but why is it
the right choice I'll give you another
example of where where this can come up
I mean they're all over the place things
that look like exponential curves but
one that's very important for
probability and statistics is the bell
curve so it's something that we almost
always write in the form e to the
negative x squared and a way you might
think about this by the way is you know
if we take just e to the X we get this
thing that grows and it kind of decays
as you go to the left and if we made it
negative you would decay as you go to
the right
so whenever the input to e to the X is
getting very negative it decays so to
make it decay on both sides you could
take e to the negative x squared and
then it's decaying on both sides and you
get this nice bell curve and because of
that square it sort of smooths things
out whereas if we have taken something
like the you know the absolute value of
x but negated it okay then it decays on
both sides but we get this awkward cusp
that doesn't explain why this very
specific curve comes up in statistics
but if you ever kind of want to remember
oh what was the what was the formula for
a bell curve again you can kind of think
through the fact that this should have
roughly that shape and quite often it
comes with some kind of parameters
though for example I could put in
something maybe a value I'll call s in
there they will determine how wide and
skinny this bell curve is something like
a standard deviation in the context of
statistics
s wouldn't be that standard deviation we
would have to reciprocate it and square
it and do some things but the idea that
when you tweak what's in that exponent
it changes the bell curve that's the
only point I want to make here you can
think just looking at this that somehow
bell curves are produced by the number e
but that's not exactly true because I
could also write a to the negative x
squared and I get the same family of
curves as I tweaked the value of a I'm
also changing what that width is so I
could come up with other ways of
describing the standard deviation of
this in terms of a and it's it's the
same family of curves it's not just that
they look similar they are in fact the
same thing and this is not too hard to
show algebraically it almost makes it
look a little bit more deceptively
simple than it really is so we've got a
lot of answers for what people wanted to
enter as an example number to go with so
let's go ahead and see it seems like the
most popular answer by a little margin
above I is 69 which I assume is because
if you take all of the natural numbers
between 1 and 9 and then you look at the
divisors for each one of those look at
the numbers you list all their divisors
and you add up the divisors it adds up
to 69 and adding up divisors like this
is a very fun and common thing in number
theory so I assume that's why people
chose it but the point here is that if
you see some kind of function like let's
see how should I write it 69 to the
power X I could also write that I could
write the same thing as e to the power
of the natural log of 69 ok net I've
written that kind of sloppily let me do
it again
e to the natural log of 69 that's the
same thing as the number 69 right
because it's saying e to the what equals
69 but then I've taken a to that so I
should get 69 back all of that to the
power X and by the rules of
Exponential's this is the same thing as
e to just some constant whatever the
natural log of 69 is times X so I could
replace that with a constant which
happens to be around 4 point 2 3 4 as
any mathematician will be able to tell
you well known constant of nature the
natural log of 69 and the point here is
that this just looks like e
to some constant times X so you might
wonder why do we make this choice right
because it didn't have to be pi I could
write that same function sorry it didn't
have to be e I could write that same
function as pi raised to a special power
namely the log base pi and I'm writing
quite sloppily here log base PI of 69
times X that would be the same function
we could describe everything with a base
of Pi if we wanted to and to just give
one more example of where I think this
even though it's a like it's a simple
conversion if you know logarithms that
anything that looks like a to the X can
be expressed as e to something times
that I think it's clearly not very
appreciated that you can make that
conversion because any time that we talk
about imaginary Exponential's and I get
that it's a kind of a weird thing to
talk about e to the I times T once
someone learns you know and I've made a
number of videos in this series about it
math Oliver has videos lots of people
have videos about it the idea is that e
to the imaginary constant time some
value t walks you around the unit circle
and in fact it walks you a distance of T
radians and the importance of this the
way that it comes up in for example
electrical engineering is it gives you
this oscillating pattern as you scale up
T you have something that's oscillating
and it gives a very nice way to describe
sine waves and cosine waves and and
signals that oscillate and there's
actually one electrical engineer that I
used to know and he would always say oh
I love the number e what I like about a
is it's the number that spins that's
really what makes a special I realized
this e is the number that spins but the
problem is that's not that's not exactly
true
what it is true that e to the I T spins
around but that's not special to e I
could also take two to the I times T and
that will also produce values that walk
around a circle and we can think through
more exactly two is the same thing as e
to the natural log of two so two to the
I T is the same as e to the natural log
of two times T all of that times the
imaginary number I which basically means
it's doing the same thing as e to the I
T
it's just rescaling time it's walking a
little bit more slowly and then
similarly if you were to take something
like your favorite number to the I times
T that would look like e to the
approximately four point two three four
times T all times the imaginary number
which just means you're walking around
at a different rate so E is not the
number that spins the idea of complex
exponents walking around a circle
doesn't have to do with e per se it
really just has to do with a lot of what
we talked about I think in lectures four
and five and I'll go over it again in
just a moment here as a quick reminder
so the thing that's special about e the
reason that we always choose to write
things in this way has to do with rates
of change that when you take the
derivative of e to the power T I this is
the same thing as itself which is to say
if we were to graph this you know maybe
e to the T represents an amount of money
you have over time or something like
that and we were to look above a value
of T the slope of this graph the rate at
which its increasing is actually equal
to its own height so the farther you are
along the curve meaning you have a
greater height the steeper it is so you
know the more money you have the faster
it grows this is the power of compound
growth but that's actually true of any
exponential what makes a special is that
they're exactly the same it's not just
that they grow in proportion with each
other so if we were to write a family of
exponential curves as e to the R times T
as opposed to writing it as a to the
power T and thinking of changing that
value a the value in doing that is that
taking the derivative by the chain rule
we take the derivative of the inside
which looks like R and we multiply by
the derivative of the outside which is e
to the RT and if anybody here doesn't
know calculus by the way we're about to
start doing a fair amount of it I have a
whole series on it that you can pop over
and take a look at lots of other places
on YouTube and such to give a quick
primer but if you're coming in and
you're not familiar with calculus like
just be warned that that's where we're
about to start going because if you want
to understand natural
and by extension the number II the
importance that they have has everything
to do with rates of change and the
inverse of that operation as you'll see
so anyway why would it be nice to
express a function like this well what
it's telling you let's say this was
something like the size of your
investment this is an expression saying
how much money you have at a given point
in time if you want to know the rate of
change of that how much is it changing
per unit time it's proportional to
itself and R gives you that
proportionality constant if R was 0.01
it's telling you that the rate of growth
is 10% of the size of the thing itself
so the choice that we make to write
things this way is it's basically a way
to make all the constants involved more
readable so if you're to look at these
statistics associated with bell curves
and the way that we actually tend to
write things the pattern ends up looking
something like 1 divided by s squared
and sometimes that X instead of writing
it as X strange parentheses I might say
X minus M for some value of M both of
these terms end up having really nice
readable meanings where M this isn't
specific to the e fact but it's just a
common thing you'll see M gives you the
mean of the distribution where this pile
is and s gives you the standard
deviation and when we choose to write
this family with E it's giving those
constants readable meanings and and a
similar thing happens with how we
describe complex Exponential's when we
choose to write the idea of walking
around a circle with E it gives a very
readable meaning to what this term T is
it's saying what is the distance that
you've walked along the unit circle and
you can actually understand this with
derivatives pretty well where if we say
what is the derivative what is the rate
of change of some value that looks like
e to the I times T by the chain rule
this is going to look like I times
itself e to the I times T now what would
that actually mean that means that if
you're sitting at some kind of number
okay if this is your current value for e
to the I times T and the rate of change
is I multiplied by that value which is a
90-degree rotation of this vector maybe
I would draw it like this this right
here would give you your rate of change
so you might move that over and consider
it a velocity vector so this is kind of
like your velocity vector this is kind
of like your position vector which I
might write something like an S so what
this whole expression of e to the I
times T is essentially saying is
whatever this does if it's somewhere in
the complex plane at every given point
the rate of change of my vector is a 90
degree rotation of itself and so that's
why we're walking around the circle at a
speed of one unit per second because the
length of the position vector is one so
the length of the velocity vector is one
and it's also why if you were to look at
two to the I T it walks around at a
different rate because they're the
constant is not just I a 90 degree
rotation it's I times let natural log of
2 I times something would mean that this
where are we this operation here is not
just a 90 degree rotation it's a 90
degree rotation and a scaling so your
velocity vector would end up looking a
little bit shorter and you'd be walking
around the unit circle more slowly so
that's kind of the important thing to
understand about E the fact that it's a
choice that we're making to write
families of Exponential's this way but
because it is its own derivative that
ends up making these things play much
more nicely now this lets us take
derivatives of anything else if you
wanted if you did describe your monies
rate of growth with a to the T to take
its derivative you could first do a
conversion write the whole thing as e to
the natural log of a times T and the
reason you would is then when we're sort
of squished my font here then when
you're taking the derivative of that the
derivative of the inside is the natural
log of a and then that's multiplied by
itself e to the natural log of a times T
which you could then spell out even
further convert it back into a to the T
so if you did describe all of your
investments as a to the power T which
kind of feels more natural to a lot of
people that oh you might say
rather than e to some investment rate
times T just think of 1.05 to the T and
that describes you know something like
5% growth if you were thinking of that
growth in a continuous sense not you
know year-over-year what's the new
percentage but moment-by-moment what's
the rate of growth you would have to say
the rate of growth is the natural log of
that base which just feels a little bit
more awkward you could do it but it
would feel more awkward now all of this
leaves open the question of why why on
earth is the derivative of e to the T
equal to itself it's this very nice
property so you might wonder where this
thing comes from and it really has
everything to do with how you how you
define the number e and this can be a
little bit frustrating where in some
contexts you'll see people say what is
the number e well it's the number
defined such that this derivative equals
itself and then other contexts you might
find a defined in it in a different way
that is very conducive to whatever the
circumstance there is so you might
wonder ok can we come up come at this a
little bit more directly and to try to
understand derivatives of Exponential's
and see why this special value 2.718
would fit into it and to do that let me
buy myself a new graph here let's say I
have some kind of exponential and if I
want to understand the rate of change
okay the slope tangent to that point X
the way we often think about it is think
of two nearby points so another one that
might be X plus a little constant times
H and then we're going to look at the
slope between those two points and
consider what happens as H goes towards
zero
so if this whole graph was a function a
to the X if we wanted to give a very
direct look at what might the derivative
of this expression be we can make an
attempt to calculate it ourselves
without depending on a pre-established
fact handed down from on high that e to
the T is or I guess in this case e to
the X is its own derivative and then
manipulate based on natural logs and
such so what does this look like if you
try to come at it directly
well what you would say is that the
change in the height of the graph
divided by the change in the width the
sort of rise over run dy/dx
looks like the difference in the outputs
at those two values so the output at the
high value which is X plus h minus the
value at the low value a to the X all of
that divided by the step in the X
direction which is just of size H and
the fact that we are doing calculus here
that we have the little DS that is a
signal to us that we don't just want
this ratio for a particular value of H
we want to consider what that ratio
change in Y change in X looks like as
the change in X goes to 0 and here I'm
writing that change in X is H so it's a
limit as H goes to 0 of this expression
and from here you can try to manipulate
it a little bit and see what you might
find the first step take advantage of
the exponential properties to write this
as a to the x times a to the H and
what's nice about that is it lets us
factor out an 8 to the X because it
shows up both in the first term and the
second so I could write this whole thing
as a limit of a to the X outside of a to
the H minus 1 all over H and this was
the limit as H goes to 0 all right well
X has nothing to do with the H here so
we're allowed to pull out the a to the X
term itself as far as H is concerned
it's just some constant rescaling the
thing and the limit of the constant
times a thing is that constant times the
limit of the thing a times or a to the x
times the limit as H goes to 0 of 8 to
the H minus 1 over H and at this point
we're a little bit stuck we've found a
very interesting fact which is that any
kind of exponential e or whatever you
want based PI to the X 2 to the X 69 to
the X those have derivatives that are
proportional to themselves but we want
to understand this proportionality
constant and I could ask you to guess
just to see if you can get a feel for it
in the context of one particular example
so let's say that
I'm choosing a base of something like
two and I want to understand rates of
change of 2 to the X our question asks
us the limit below I guess it tells us
it tells us a little bit about what it
is the limit below is a number between 0
& 1 so this is we're looking at 2 to a
small value minus 1 divided by that same
small value don't worry about
calculating it exactly I'm just kind of
curious if you guessed enter some kind
of guess for what this value is and then
round it to two decimal places so we can
have some consistency so we'll give you
a moment to just think of what it might
be but don't think too hard if you don't
want to it's it's totally okay to get
this one wrong we just want to see what
people think
[Music]
[Music]
looks like we've got a couple things
coming in from the audience here which
is always fun so Robert points out that
in French the notation reads local idiom
the area and as wondering why this word
is used I asked this on Twitter the
other day evidently it's in reference to
a person I think John nappy a and so
it's like in reference to him and then
there was a truly terrible French pun
about like an exponential and a
logarithm walk into a bar and they order
a beer and like who pays and the answer
is that the exponential has to pay
because the logarithm the pay via which
anyone who speaks French were like groan
and laugh at but that made me laugh a
little bit do I have a personal invent a
yeah yeah I do I think it's an overrated
constant I think it's beautiful but I
think it's beautiful in ways that aren't
what people think they are and I also
think that I'm gonna talk about this in
moment we should write we shouldn't
write the exponential function is e to
the X because when it's more general
that doesn't make sense and I think it
confuses people we should just write it
as what it is which is a certain
polynomial and just be honest up front
rather than letting eat like he has
nothing to do with e to the PI I that's
a frustrating fact it shouldn't be in
there
anyway German here is normal for how you
do maths on a rural paper instead of
graph paper
I mean graph paper is definitely nicer
but I know this this was the paper that
I just had on hand and in general if you
want to make any comments or questions
about the lesson you can do so on
Twitter with the hashtag walk down math
and those will be pulled up as we go so
it seems like we have strong consensus
on our guess here which is people
guessing that the correct answer to this
limit is that it's around 0.69 which I
assume the reason everybody guessed that
is because it's the correct answer that
this limit does in fact approach around
0.69 and we could play with Python if we
wanted to see that experimentally
pythons kind of overkill here you can do
it with any calculator but if I raise 2
to some small power right I get some
kind of number and if I subtract 1 from
that then I get a small number and if I
divide it by the same small power so
here I had three zeros than a 1
it looks like we get around 0.6931 and
if I made it a smaller value that I was
doing it seems to stay pretty stable
around there it's around 0.6931 4 so
congratulations to the majority of you
who had the right guess here and in fact
it's no coincidence that that's what it
is because like I said earlier if you
were taking the derivative where have I
written it I've written it somewhere
sloppily as I am wanted to do I've
written that if you take the derivative
of something that looks like a to the T
the constant sitting in front is the
natural log of a so for something like 2
you would be looking at the natural log
of 2 which is in fact around zero point
six nine now all of that was dependent
on the fact that e to the X is its own
derivative right so there's one Avenue
that you could take here if you want to
come up with a definition of e what you
could say and this is totally valid is
the number E is to define it defined to
be the constant such that this limit is
1 if that's the case then e to the X is
its own derivative by definition pretty
much and then from there you will get
the fact that anything else its
derivative can be expressed in terms of
the log base e of of itself that's one
way that you could go another Avenue
that you could take is to say that when
we write e to the X this is actually
shorthand for a certain polynomial I'm
partial to this because I think this is
an honest representation of the role
that it plays more generally like when
we start talking about complex numbers
it's weird to me that in high school I
saw Euler's formula as the polar
representation for complex numbers
before it was ever really explained that
e to the X does not refer to the
repeated multiplication that it's a
shorthand for this long polynomial you
might give it another name like X all
right and then that's something that it
makes sense to plug in complex numbers
to traditionally the way that you see
this series in high school is you might
go through a calculus class where you
learn about e to the X being its own
derivative and then maybe at the end of
a second calculus class the fact that
its own it is its own
derivative in conjunction with a very
wonderful topic called paler series it's
a it being its own derivative and Taylor
series except eetu the X must equal this
long polynomial which is absolutely the
case right if you have a function that
is its own derivative and at the value 0
it equals 1 you you will find that it
has to equal this polynomial an
alternate approach that you could take
if you wanted in setting the foundations
is to say don't worry about Taylor
series start with this sequence as a
primitive object and then something we
talked about a couple lectures ago was
because of a nice property that this
function has which is basically that
when you add the inputs basically this
polynomial behaves like an exponential
and you can prove that just from the
polynomial itself without calculus or
anything X of a plus B equals X both a
times X both B and it's a very pleasing
exercise to kind of work out the
expansion and see that that works and
the fact that that works we talked about
this a couple lectures ago implies that
the whole sequence looks like whatever X
but one is raised to the X so what you
could say is the number E is defined to
be this particular sequence evaluated at
x equals 1 and if you go that direction
that's all well and good and it becomes
a kind of substantive thing to talk
about e to the X being its own
derivative and it's one of the most
pleasing exercises that you'll ever do
because we can take a look at this and
if you know how to take derivatives of
polynomial terms well let's just work it
out actually I'll turn over a new leaf
so that it can be nice and cleanly seen
it's really one of the most pleasing I
don't know times that you'll have in a
calculus class if you're just sitting
you're looking at this particular
infinite polynomial and you're saying I
wonder what the derivative of this
happens to be and all you need to know
is the power rule for polynomial terms
and you'll say that the derivative you
take DDX well the derivative of a
constant ends up being zero the
derivative of X is 1
the derivative of x squared over two you
know you might think of that two is kind
of hopping down in front and leaving one
less than itself so it's it becomes two
times X to the one just next to the one
over two and those twos cancel so we're
adding X X cubed over three factorial I
might write this out as X cubed over
three times two times one
this ends up being three times x squared
you know the exponential the exponent
kind of hopped down and left behind one
minus itself over three times two times
one the threes cancel so we can see that
that's actually the same as x squared
over two factorial
and in general each one of our terms as
the exponent hops down it cancels out
one of the things from the factorials
below it and what we get is the exact
same sequence but shifted which is quite
nice and like I said the the traditional
way that you see this series is that
you're using the fact that e to the X is
its own derivative in conjunction with
Taylor series to show that it must equal
this but if you start with this as a
primitive and you say this is the thing
that defines a special function for
which we use the shorthand e to the X
then it feels a little bit more content
'fl and quite fun to say that e to the X
ends up being its own derivative and
like we showed earlier that then lets
you take the derivative of all sorts of
other things which in turn explains why
we adopt the convention of writing all
of our Exponential's as e to something
times T as opposed to writing them all
as a to something times T even though
those are equivalent and often weirdly
hard to appreciate so with all of that
said we can turn ourselves back in the
direction of natural logarithms because
let's say I wanted to know the
derivative of the natural log you might
wonder why I want to know that but if I
have a bit you know a deeper
relationship with the natural log of X
in terms not just of how it relates to
these series but in all facets of math
maybe we can then start drawing
connections and if you build up that
relationship by knowing things like
derivative it actually helps you come
back and understand things like the
alternating series we were looking at
before so can we use the fact that e to
the X is its own derivative to figure
out the slope of a natural log curve
well what that slope is asking us is to
look at a given input X we consider a
tiny step DX to the right look at the
corresponding step dy up and we want to
understand the ratio dy over DX now at
this point which has some kind of output
Y what we can say is by definition Y is
the natural log of X now this is the
same statement as saying 'i have written
this right why is natural the act great
so this is the same as saying e to the Y
is equal to X okay now from there I can
understand the relationship between tiny
nudges to X and tiny nudges to Y by
taking derivatives if I ask about you
know some tiny nudge to the value X and
the corresponding tiny nudge to e to the
Y well what it means for e to the X or
in this case e to the Y to be its own
derivative is that the size of that tiny
nudge is e to whatever the Y value at
that point is x dy and we're saying that
that equals DX and what this lets us do
then is express the slope that we want
dy over DX if we just rearrange things
it looks like 1 divided by e to the Y so
what this is saying is that if we look
at our graph it's got some x-coordinate
some y-coordinate and i want to know
what the slope is this changed to Y over
change in X
I can't immediately express it in terms
of X maybe but I do know whatever this
value of y is if I take e to the power
of that and then reciprocate that gives
me the slope but of course what it means
to be on our graph is that Y is the
natural log of X which is the same as
saying e to the y equals x so this whole
thing is the same as taking 1 divided by
X so if I want to know that slope I can
say what is your ex corde
take 1 divided by that and that gets me
the slope of the natural log which is
we've just gone through a process called
implicit differentiation if you're not
inclined to believe that this
manipulation is legitimate that we can
just move around the DX's and duis like
that I have a whole video about implicit
differentiation in the calculus series
that you can take a look at but the
point for us is that we have a very nice
fact that the derivative of Ln of X
looks like 1 divided by X and that's
quite nice and it kind of passes a
gut-check that Ln of X gets shallower
and shallower as you go on which means
the slope gets smaller and smaller and
the graph of 1 over X you know what does
that look like well at the input let's
say we have the input 1 somewhere like
here it'll be at 1 at the input 2 it'll
be sitting at 1/2 at the input 3 it'll
be sitting at 1/3 and in general it gets
lower and lower and closer to zero okay
so the idea that this would describe the
slope of that you know something that
gets lower and lower closer to zero
seems to pass a little bit of a sanity
check now the relevance that this is
going to have to us will involve the
inverse operation to differentiation so
instead of talking about what is the
slope of the natural log curve what I
might do is ask about the area under
this particular curve let's say I take
the area up to my stomach was just
rumbling I don't know if that's audible
on the on the microphone clearly gotta
eat lunch before these things so let's
say I want to understand the area up to
N of something like this okay what that
what that involves is taking the
integral between 1 and our value n of 1
divided by X by DX now this actually
looks quite similar in spirit the idea
of adding up a bunch of things that look
like 1 over X to what we were looking at
earlier how much earlier I guess over
here where we're adding up 1 plus 1/2
plus
third plus a fourth on and on and
already it gives a little bit of an
intuitive instinct for why something
like this some would be related to
natural logs because we now know that in
calculus land natural logs are
intimately related to the idea of one
divided by x but I want you to think of
this spelled out a little bit more
exactly and so we'll pop on over to our
quiz one more time second to last
question for today and the question is
asks us all right we can we're gonna let
s be the sum from N equals 1 up to
capital n of 1 divided by n ok that's s
and then we're going to let I be an
analogous integral where we're
integrating DX over X between 1 and N
and it asks you to compare s and I ok
I'll give you a moment to think about
that
[Music]
interestingly we don't have a ton of
consensus around this one so there's
only three options and we've got a nice
split and as you guys know this is
actually one of my favorite things when
we do any of these lockdown live quizzes
is when it's not you know everyone
hopping on to one particular thing but
we have a division among folks and I
think that's great
I'm curious I mean I'm curious actually
what the what the answer is going to be
here and in fact even if it's not been
enough time to you know thoroughly think
through I'm gonna go ahead and grade it
just so that we can see what it happens
to be and a lot of these de spirit of it
is that you kind of hazard a guess so
feel no shame if you entered an answer
and then it's not what turns out to be
correct so in this case the sum does in
fact end up being bigger than the
integral and it looks like 900 of you
got that correct which is awesome and
then following that was people thinking
that it was less and then to those and
be thinking that they were identical you
know that's that's a reasonable thought
because there's such similar expressions
but there's a picture that really makes
the answer kind of shine out to us here
which is if I look at the curve 1 over X
which is what this white curve is it's 1
over X and then I'm going to consider a
bunch of bars each of whose area
corresponds to 1 over N for some value
of n so for example for the value 1 this
bar has a width of 1 and then the height
is 1 and that means that right above the
input 1 on its upper left corner it's
hitting the graph now for the next term
if I want 1 over 2 that means it's going
to hit the graph above the input 2 since
the graph is defined to be 1 over X so
it's upper left corner hits that and
then the area of this bar whose height
is 1/2 is well 1/2 because its width is
1 similarly this bar has an area of 1
third this bar has an area of 1/4 and so
what you have is a sequence of
rectangles whose total area is going to
be similar to the area under the curve
definitely similar but you can tell that
it's going to be bigger because some of
the area is leaking out in this context
we've got a lot of area we
hangout from the first bar a little bit
less licking out from the second and on
and on but as you go because the graph
flattens out it becomes quite a good
approximation once you account for the
area that's leaked out there now
something kind of bizarre is happening
here where usually we think of these
rectangles as being something like a
Riemann sum that defines integration
where we say oh we don't know what the
area under a curve is but we like areas
of rectangles so we use the rectangles
to approximate the curve here we're
going to do something that's backwards
to that if we know calculus we do know
the area under the curve it's very nice
it involves the antiderivative of 1 over
X like we'll show in a moment what we
don't know is the sum of the areas of
the rectangles that was the sum that we
were looking at earlier and trying to
understand so here we're going backwards
and using the area under a curve to
approximate the area of a bunch of
rectangles which i think is fun it shows
that calculus has this back and forth
it's not just geometry in forming
understanding of curves but it's an
understanding of curves in forming an
understanding of geometry and number
theory and things of that sort
so what this means for us is that if we
take a look back at our paper and we
look at my much more sloppily drawn
graph then the beautiful exact
illustrations can give us if we want to
understand that area taking this
integral the task is to do an inverse
derivative to ask what function has a
derivative that equals the inside here
if that's something you haven't learned
about again calculus series take a look
at the fundamental theorem of calculus
video or even the first video in that
series I think shows a little of an
instinct for why you have this
relationship between slopes and areas
but what it means for us is that we take
the inverse derivative which we now know
is the natural log the thing whose
derivative is 1 over X is the natural
log and we evaluate it at the bounds at
N and 1 and this notation where I kind
of put brackets around it and then a
number in the upper right corner and
lower right corner means I take that
expression evaluated at the top - that
expression evaluated at the bottom yeah
and that well natural log of 1 what is
that
e to the what equals one well it's zero
right pretty much anything to the zero
will equal one so this term goes away
entirely and what we're left with is the
natural log of n and what this means for
us is if we were using our rectangles to
approximate the sum or using the the
integral to approximate those rectangles
it's saying that 1 over 1 plus 1 over 2
plus 1 over 3 on and on up to a given
bound is about equal to the natural log
of N and more specifically if you were
to account for how much area is leaking
out here that area actually does
converge as n toward tends towards
infinity the area that's leaked out
approaches a certain constant and it's a
it's called Euler's constant or the
euler mesh maccheroni constant and it
happens to be around 0.577 so in the
same way that PI and E are constants of
nature this is another constant of
nature also bearing Euler's name and
what it what it describes is the
deviation between this sum often called
the harmonic sum and the natural log of
X a thing that is related to e so Euler
has really got his fingerprints all over
the situation at least as far as naming
is concerned in our little expression
here so that's quite nice that's quite
fun but that only answers one of the
mysteries that we had earlier is if
you'll remember I opened this whole
thing up by talking not just about this
series that grows like the natural log
we also alternated it we went 1 minus
1/2 plus 1/3 minus 1/4 and the claim is
that that was the natural log of 2 so
let's see if we can try to understand
why that's true and I might I might
actually postponed explaining the even
more bizarre fact that this interrelates
with primes in a certain way depending
on how long I want this particular
stream to go but let's at least finish
off by understanding the alternating
series because it's extremely satisfying
so to do that let me just rewrite what
our series looks like
and this is one of those things where as
I go through the answer it has a feeling
of magic and sometimes not in a great
way you might find yourself looking at
how we go about this and asking how on
earth would anyone ever come up with
that and maybe after we plop it all down
we can try to introspect and think about
the reasonable ways that someone would
come up with the following line of
reasoning but it it is not unique to
this situation it's kind of a useful set
of tricks to be familiar with and
there's a couple general principles in
there
the first general principle is that if
we have a hard question in this case
figuring out what this some approaches
bizarrely it can become easier if we
make it more general you might think
that making things more general how
would make it harder because you have to
answer a more powerful fact but math
does this bizarre thing where sometimes
by trying to make it more general you
actually make the problem more tractable
which is quite cool actually because
what it means is when a mathematician is
motivated only by making their own life
easier it has the strange effect of
making their results applicable to a
wider variety of circumstances
so the way I'm going to generalize this
again it might look kind of bizarre and
unmotivated but run with me for a second
is rather than thinking of a single
value I'm gonna put an X in here and
consider this a function where I'm
taking x over 1 minus x squared over 2
plus X cubed over 3 on and on and on and
I want to know in general what does this
approach for various values of X and
then I just have to plug in the value x
equals 1 and like I said that might make
it seem harder infinitely harder
previously we just had to know one value
now you're asking me to compute
infinitely many values but if you know
calculus you might recognize that the
exponents of your polynomial terms might
just play nicely with the denominators
here and in particular if we were to
take the derivative of this series it
behaves quite nicely the derivative of X
is 1 the derivative of x squared over 2
well that 2 hops down and cancels out
the denominator so it becomes negative X
similarly that three hops down and
cancels the denominator so it becomes x
squared and while you might not know why
we're taking a derivative of something
here and how that would be helpful for
actually evaluating the the ultimate sum
that we care about it is an interesting
fact and it's something that is playful
and fun that we've somehow simplified
the expression by taking its derivative
and the simplification is actually quite
important because there's a well-known
fact within math that you can take a
series where each term is the product of
the last with a constant kind of product
so here as we go from one term to the
next we're always multiplying by
negative x so to go from negative x to x
squared you multiply by negative x and
then similarly x squared to negative x
cubed you're multiplying by negative x
and when that's the case the series as a
whole is going to approach one divided
by or wherever you start but here we
started at one so the thing you started
at divided by one minus the thing that
you're constantly multiplying by which
is negative x so to give another example
of what where this comes up is if we
were to take something like 1 plus 1/2
plus 1/4 where each time in our sequence
we are multiplying the last term by 1/2
this will equal 1 divided by 1 minus the
thing we were multiplying by which was
1/2 and 1 divided by 1 minus 1/2 ends up
being the same as 2 and that actually
kind of feels intuitive that if we take
1 plus 1/2 plus 1/4 plus 1/8 you could
even draw out a picture where let's say
I've got a rectangle whose side length
is 1 and 1 here I can say the 1
represents this area and then 1/2
represents this area and then 1/4
represents this area then 1/8 represents
that area and kind of keep playing this
game and eventually it'll fill an area
of 2 now the more general version of
that is this geometric sum which someone
who's done a lot of problem solving in
math is a
to recognize kind of quickly which is
why they might enjoy this series much
more than they would enjoy the one above
it so this whole thing ends up looking
like 1/1 + x
great but what this suggests is that if
we somehow take an antiderivative if we
somehow integrate this we might have an
alternate expression for what the the
initial sequence was okay so from here
I'm gonna go ahead and pose a quiz and
part of this quiz is seeing who in the
audience is comfortable with calculus
and again if you're not calculus series
go and check it out but what we have
here is the question what is the
integral from 0 up to 1 of 1 divided by
1 plus X DX okay
I want you to evaluate that integral and
I'll give you I'll give you a little
moment for this one
the
and you know tell you what while answers
are rolling in before locking it in I'm
going to go ahead and just start
describing the answer here so if you
want to know the integral from 0 up to 1
of 1 divided by 1 plus X DX well we know
that the antiderivative of 1 over X is
the natural log of X so it's going to be
the natural log of that inside divided
by the derivative of the inside that's
kind of the inverse chain rule or
something you can get with you
substitution but the derivative of the
inside is just 1 so you can check
yourself that if you take the derivative
of this you get 1 over the inside 1 over
1 plus X but then the chain rule just
has you multiplying by 1 so it stays the
same so then we evaluate this at the
bounds 1 and 0 and what this ends up
getting us is the natural log at the top
which is 1 plus 1 minus the natural log
of 1 plus X at the bottom which was 1
plus 0 the natural log of 1 plus 1 is of
course
Ln of 2 and then we're subtracting off
the natural log of 1 which is 0 so the
proper answer here comes out to be the
natural log of 2 and it looks like 1600
of you have correctly answered that so
well done well done indeed
and if you wanted to kind of visualize
this in your head or get some sort of
like gut instinct on which of those
answers seemed loosely correct even if
you didn't know how to calculate it
immediately the graph of 1 over 1 plus X
is going to look just like the graph of
1 over X but shifted to the left so it's
actually going to pass through the input
0 1 and then we're looking for the area
under here so you know that it's going
to be an area somewhere between 0 & 1
probably filling up more than 1/2 of it
and the natural log of 2 is around 0.69
so that that actually seems about right
but what's quite cool here is that if we
say that the well I can just I guess
write it write it out again here if I
say I want to integrate this bottom
expression
from zero up to one okay which is the
same as integrating 1 over 1 plus X from
0 up to 1 I know that that should be the
value to Ellen of two okay but on the
other hand if I picture taking my
antiderivative and getting this whole
sequence here and evaluating it between
0 and 1 what I'm doing is I'm plugging
in the number 1 which gets me my
alternating sequence then I'm
subtracting off the value of 0 which
when I plug it in just get 0 so
evaluating this as 0 and 1 is the same
thing as integrating the bottom
expression from 0 to 1 which is the same
thing as integrating 1 over 1 plus X
from 0 to 1 which is the same thing as
natural log of 2 and hence that whole
top thing ends up being the natural log
of 2 very clever
just such a sneaky sequence of
manipulations that like I said if you
just see a plopped down almost as
intimidating because you wonder how on
earth do you go from seeing this
sequence up here to thinking about ah
yes if I generalize it with lots of
powers of X and then take the
derivatives of those and then use a
geometric series sum and then integrate
that using natural log yes then it'll
all become obvious and I think the
answer is that that's probably not what
the problem solving process looks like
instead you build up a familiarity with
a lot of these things like derivatives
of polynomial terms and then you build
up familiarity with other things like
derivatives of natural logs and the more
familiar do you have with a lot of
different pieces of math then sometimes
when you see one particular pattern
you're able to draw on your mind a
connection to things that make you look
like a genius
I think oiler did this all the time if
you look at some of the great
discoveries of Euler they just come
really out of nowhere I mean the very
opening thing that I talked about I
guess it wasn't a very opening but early
on where we seem to have the the sum of
the reciprocals of squares which
somewhere in my notebook here we were
just looking at the pages maybe I tore
it out oh yeah another beer
things can become a little bit of a mess
over here but if we look at this this
long somewhere we're taking 1 over 1
squared 1 over 2 squared and equals PI
squared over 6 the way that Euler found
this I mean it involves this very
strange thing where you start looking at
an infinite product associated with sine
of pi times X and if you think of it as
starting with this sum and then dreaming
up out of your head an infinite product
associated with sine of pi times X or
might have been cotangent of pi times X
or something like that it really does
seem like it came out of nowhere but in
general I think you build up these bits
of familiarity with different pieces and
then once you see something like oiler
seeing that basal problem some or
someone seeing this alternating harmonic
some be able to use those connections to
kind of make yourself look smarter than
you actually are which is fun and if
nothing else it helps motivate the idea
of just being playful with your calculus
and being playful with your math purely
for the motivation of exposing yourself
to more patterns and